[Musique]
dieu veut que les innocents soient la
question est de savoir ce qui se passe
quand cela n'est pas le cas comme dans
le cas de ce monsieur quand il a été
condamné à tort okah a été dominée par
le mal cet homme a été faussement accusé
pour la perdu 20 ans de sa vie qui sait
combien d'abus il a peut-être dû subir
en prison ça a été terrible bourreau et
à des soins
c'est l'une des questions les plus
difficiles que nous en tant qu'êtres
humains nous avons un réseau performant
cette année c'est presque une question
existentielle vous voyez s'il ya un dieu
et j'en suis convaincu comment peut-il
laisser le mal avoir lieu
oui j'ai souvent interrogé dieu une
menace
tout ce que je veux savoir c'est la
vérité la question de savoir pourquoi
est crucial dans ma vie tout nu
[Musique]
mais jérôme morgan j'ai 42 ans j'étais
arrêté par erreur reconnue coupable et
condamnée à l'âge de 17 ans pour un
meurtre que je n'ai pas commis
j'ai été condamné à perpétuité je devais
mourir en prison
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais 17 ans quand on m'a arrêté le
jour des 41 ans de ma mère
le 7 octobre 1993 lui
[Musique]
il y avait la soirée d'anniversaire
d'une jeune fille appelée mujica yang
c'était ses 16 ans fréquenté la même
école en troisième en fait elle avait
invité geffray jackson un de mes
meilleurs amis et lui nous a emmenés
là-bas nous
[Musique]
c'est mon vieux comment ça va ça roule à
l'eau au motel holly johnson pour voir
comment tout a changé
d'accord pour voir comment tout a changé
si rien n'a changé et on va essayer
d'expliquer comment c'est arrivé
d'accord parce que bon allons-y
[Musique]
cette nuit là on s'est tous retrouvé un
coin de middle street et d'esther street
jérôme a grandi oui vivait à l'époque on
est allé à la soirée tout allait bien
c'était juste une de nos soirées
habituelles on allait souvent chez
quelqu'un pour s'amuser pour danser ou
autre chose
et là ça a tourné au drame
[Musique]
nous sommes venus ici pour filmer
quelques détails concernant le crime qui
a eu lieu à cet endroit le 26 mai 1993
je ne suis pas venu ici depuis vingt ans
la salle nous sommes que le dj était
installée devant ce mur il y avait
probablement des portes doubles
peut-être un peu plus entré nous étions
debout vous juste ici
de ce côté là comme la fusillade a eu
lieu
[Musique]
j'ai vu comment la pièce a été envahie
par la lumière
et puis il ya eu des coups de feu vous
savez ces flashs et puis pas la pièce
éclairée
ça ressemblait à la foudre quand les
tirs ont cessé quand tout le monde a
senti qu'il était possible d'aller voir
ce qui s'était passé
or on a vu qu'un corps était déjà
couvert d'un drap blanc alors à partir
ce moment là on a compris qu'il
s'agissait d'un meurtre
[Musique]
mais nos appuis je dirais quelques
semaines plus tard nous avons appris que
jérôme était recherché pour meurtre faut
nommer
à se demander comment est ce possible
s'ils étaient avec nous et l'amour quoi
est il est recherché pour le meurtre
d'un cafouillage
comment il pourrait être celui qui a
commis le crime
s'ils étaient ici près de nous après que
le crime ait été commis et je veux dire
c'est absurde a testé la police a
entendu parler de jérôme morgan à cause
des rumeurs qui circulaient concernant
l'identité du tireur
ensuite la police a pris une photo de
jérôme et dans les archives photos de
son collège ils ont primé des photos
pour les montrer aux témoins clés lors
d'une séance d'identification
pour lui les policiers lui ont demandé
connaissez-vous jérôme organes il a
répondu oui je le connais où nous avons
besoin que vous veniez avec nous et que
vous choisissez une photo de jérôme
morgan noter que l'inspecteur n'a pas
demandé de choisir la photo du tireur
ce qu'il a dit c'est il faut que vous
veniez et choisissiez jérôme organes
cela faire à attirer l'attention des
médias
il s'agissait d'une fusillade lors de la
fête d'anniversaire d'une fille de 16
ans donc je pense que la police était
pressé de clore la faire je ne sais pas
vraiment si le but était de résoudre
l'affairé
il s'agissait plutôt de fermer le
dossier est de trouver quelqu'un à faire
passer pour responsable
j'ai témoigné j'ai dit que jérôme
n'était pas le tireur que j'avais été
témoin du fait qu'il n'était pas le
tireur
parce que j'étais juste à côté de lui
ils ont bien sûr dit conformer en gang
ont été des amis de gérone et que donc
on dirait n'importe quoi pour le tirer
d'un mauvais pas au gala
debout on essayait de cacher la vérité
mais on disait la vérité
j'ai demandé à jeff qu'est ce que ça
veut dire quand il décide et ils m'ont
dit jérôme a été condamné à 40 ans de
prison ou à la perpétuité commence à 40
ans de prison
j'étais effondrée je n'arrivais pas à
croire que c'était vrai et surtout que
cela s'était passé si vite
en gros ils ont cru aux rumeurs
quelqu'un a dit quelque chose etc
ils l'auront fait plus confiance qu'à
nous qu'à moi ramel et jérôme que jury
m'a estimé coupable de ce dont j'étais
accusé
je ne me souviens de rien après l
annonce du verdict
[Musique]
je ne me souviens même plus de ce qui
s'est passé il faudrait que quelqu'un
d'autre me rappelle tout ce qui s'est
passé parce que tout ce dont je me
souviens est totalement faux mes
premiers jours en prison était un enfer
comme je ne pouvais pas y croire tout
simplement jour et nuit je
m'interrogeais est-ce que ça n'était pas
juste un mauvais rêve est ce que j'étais
en train de faire un cauchemar but
j'espérais qu'il m'appelle un matin pour
me dire
jérôme morgan vous pouvez y aller nous
avons découvert la vérité qu'enfin la
plupart du temps je me trouvais dans la
prison d'état de louisiane
on appelle ici angola elle a été nommée
d'après le pays africains tous les états
unis ont apporté la majorité donc
l'histoire se poursuit dans cette prison
tout repose en fait sur le site de cette
prison il y avait une plantation
la prison est maintenant la plus grande
dans le pays plus de 73 kilomètres
carrés il ya plus de 5000 prisonniers et
je dirais que près de 90% d'entre eux
sont des personnes de couleur
[Musique]
il y ait de mentalité très raciste chez
les gardiens de prison fût il y avait
beaucoup de situations durant lesquelles
les gardiens abusé de leur pouvoir
l'une des règles de la prison angola et
que quand il commence à pleuvoir les
travaux dans les champs sont suspendus
une fois ils nous ont forcés de
continuer à travailler alors même que
nous étions censés nous abrités de la
pluie mais ce jour là deux prisonniers
ne voulait pas obéir et les gardiens se
sont sentis insultés il était indigné le
groupe d'intervention rapide est arrivé
immédiatement ils se sont jetés sur eux
et ont commencé à les battre en leur
donnant des coups de pied on pouvait
entendre des cris savez mon dieu et puis
il y avait du sang mais on nous a fait
nous mettre de dos pour qu'on ne puisse
rien voir si quelqu'un se retourner pour
regarder ils étaient battus et emmenés
quelque part il veut qu'il a vécu
l'enfer
il a souffert plus qu'on ne peut
l'imaginer emad alors maintenant une
mairie de profiter de la vie de se
sentir bien
je veux dire il mérite d'être heureux
quand je suis arrivé en prison savais
que je devais trouver un moyen de
subvenir à mes besoins
j'ai toujours eu un talent artistique
j'aime dessiner
donc je me suis dit que ça pouvait être
une compétence utile pour devenir
coiffeur
[Musique]
je suis devenu vraiment bon et les gars
venaient toujours chez moi pour se faire
couper les cheveux surtout ceux qui
avaient beaucoup de visites et puis je
suis devenu un vrai expert même les
gardiens venaient se faire couper les
cheveux comme ça je pouvais obtenir tout
ce dont j'avais besoin
maintenant je suis rentré chez moi après
avoir été libéré c'est devenu ma
principale source de revenus
[Musique]
dès que j'ai été mis en prison mais j'ai
commencé à chercher à prouver mon
innocence je recevais des lettres de
jérôme et il m'appelait souvent oulémas
aux places vous et puis dieu merci on a
eu la chance d'être présenté aux avocats
at d'innocence projet innocence project
new orleans était au courant de la
sphère de jérôme morgan avant même que
je ne commence à travailler ici en 2006
nous nous sommes toujours posé des
questions sur sa culpabilité taxe en
raison des faits qui avaient été
établies au cours du procès lui même ce
que tu série d'audiences
il y avait des audiences portant sur des
questions de procédure fuyez des années
plus tard nous avons finalement eu des
audiences sur le flanc de la faire il a
fallu longtemps pour que les choses
évoluent de manière positive très
longtemps il ya eu de bons résultats
entre 2003 et 2004 jusqu'à l'ouragan
mais tout a été annulé à cause de cette
catastrophe
c'est incroyablement puissant une
tempête de catégorie 5 la vitesse du
vent à temps les 265 km heure
ont été évacués de la ville de
nouvelle-orléans ya des rapports sur la
nouvelle orléans
il ya des gens qui restent bloqués dans
les bâtiments à cause d'une tempête
extrêmement puissante dans la région
après l'ouragan c'était le chaos partout
y compris dans les départements de
police avec tous leurs dossiers
il est devenu très difficile de les
obtenir la localisation de témoin clé
était incertaine on ne savait plus où
étaient les institutions judiciaires les
salles d'audience et le bureau du
procureur général du district bref tout
ce qui est nécessaire pour obtenir sa
libération
à ce moment là j'avais fait onze ou
douze ans de prison
donc quand tout a été anéanti et que
vous ne comprenais plus ce qui va se
passer ensuite
ça peut vraiment vous miner
mon fils est né en 1994
six mois après mon arrestation sonne
donc je n'ai jamais eu la chance de le
voir quand j'ai appris que j'avais un
enfant ça a été le meilleur jour de ma
vie il était encore petit je pense qu'il
avait neuf ans il a dit qu'il me
sortirait de prison
dieu me raconter combien il aimait le
football et d'autres choses
nous avons beaucoup parlé moi je vous ai
dit combien je l'aimais et que désormais
on parlerait plus souvent on resterait
en contact ou soa
[Musique]
il m'a aussi écrit un petit message sur
un bout de papier je t'aime je les
gardais jeu l'est toujours
mais en 2004 il n'est pas venu me voir
et en 2005 il est l'ouragan katrina
je ne savais pas où il était s'ils
étaient en sécurité ou s'ils avaient été
évacués je ne savais pas si mon fils se
trouvait dans la zone inondée je faisais
manifestement des progrès importants
dans beaucoup de domaines différents
j'espérais que les choses iraient
vraiment mieux' surtout concernant mon
fils ma famille et mon affaire
judiciaire
on est à cause de cet ouragan tout a été
détruit
le nettoyage après l'ouragan katrina
pour être le plus coûteux de l'histoire
des états unis
astrid veillon a beaucoup de gens
pensent que ces affaires se résolvent
d'un coup d'un seul dans le cas de
jérôme comme dans beaucoup d'autres ce
sont des petites victoires semaine
finalement la libération et à la
disculpation 10 personnes la preuve
substantielle que nous avions est le
fait indéniable que le tueur s'est enfui
de la pièce et que je rende morgan se
trouvait dans la pièce quand la police
est arrivée
on avait deux objectifs le premier était
de sape et l'accusation ont obtenu par
les autorités lors du procès et qui
appuyé sa condamnation l'autre consiste
à fournir les preuves de son innocence
et on a réussi à naples en actifs
shabazz et kevin johnson a témoigné oui
ils ont raconté ce qui s'était
réellement passé lors de la procédure
d'identification 8' police
et pourquoi il avait fait de tels
témoignages procès
[Musique]
j'ai été libéré le 4 février à 18 heures
en 2014 à s'exclure
[Musique]
je ne pouvais pas y croire mais c'était
la réalité
le jour de sa libération j'étais assise
devant mon ordinateur et je vérifiais le
site du shérif ou les informations
s'affichent sur le statut des détenus et
abidjan je clique et encore et encore
sur mettre à jour et à 16h30 ou à 17
heures environ
le site a dit aucun dossier trouver quoi
que ce soit et là j'ai compris qu'elle
avait été libérée
c'était tellement émouvant que j'avais
même peur d'exprimer mes émotions
c'était un tel bonheur j'étais présent
c'était merveilleux c'était tellement
heureux j'ai été soulagé comme si un
poids que je portais depuis des années
m'avait été enlevés donc j'imagine ce
que c'est dû être pour lui à quel point
ce fardeau était lourd sonné ouakam est
sorti je me suis dit c'est fini dieu
merci encore j'étais tellement content
comme si c'était moi même qui avait été
libéré vous savez libéré de ce fardeau
que je portais depuis que j'avais 16 ans
vous voyez ce que je veux dire une chose
que je voulais qu'il fasse lui-même
j'ouvre la porte parce que quand vous
êtes en prison on ne vous le permet pas
cette chance d'ouvrir la porte de sortie
ça aide
[Musique]
la seule chose que je savais c'était que
jérôme resterai toujours la même
personne que je n'ai pas lu perdre après
la prison dont je me mets dans sa pour
je ne sais pas c'est horrible
eh oui
[Musique]
je suis heureux qu'il soit sorti goubil
c'était beau j'aime surtout l'air de la
nuit vers du soir rien parce que j'ai
très longtemps rêvé de me promener la
nuit sous les étoiles
[Musique]
il avait l'air beaucoup plus vieux il ne
faut pas oublier qui est allé en prison
à l'âge de 16 17 ans donc il a pris du
poids et du muscle en gros il est devenu
un homme à angola nous nous sommes
arrêtés devant un magasin on avait tous
faim et ils m'ont acheté du pôle et free
qui m'avait manqué toutes ces années
et aussi mesnac préféré des cheats aussi
queen's
[Musique]
alors je dis du poulet frit avec des
kits hausse ça va pas ça
bon je comprends que c'était un premier
repas après la libération alors vas-y
mais ça nous a fait rire mais ça nous
fait toujours rire ce poulet frit avec
des kits hausse de ça ne va pas du tout
ensemble
alors oui c'était drôle ils voulaient
manger du poulet frit et c'est chitose
préférées il a toujours aimé ça c'était
son surnom au fait je me souviens de sa
digue à manger ça et il était vraiment
heureux c'était bon tout était bon n y
étais pendant cinq jours d'affilée après
ma libération je ne pouvais pas dormir
j'étais en proie à une extrême
excitation
dès aujourd'hui c'est le 4 novembre
c'est mon anniversaire une entame on va
faire la fête comme on l'a fait à la
nouvelle orléans star 9 les noirs
[Musique]
je leur manquait j'ai senti toutes ces
années en prison
je ressentais leur amour ou pour moi
pour expliquer cela de manière la plus
simple possible
ces gars m'ont sauvé la vie c'est pour
ça que j'ai cette photo là haut ou romel
mois nous étreignant le jour où j'ai été
disculpé
[Musique]
ça je suis heureux que ce soit arrivé
comme ça parce qu'au bout du compte tout
s'est bien terminé
enfin tous réunis voilà
agl matra voilà comment je m'explique
comment je réponds à la question de
savoir pourquoi dieu m'a fait ça je
reconnais maintenant que de la flamme de
ma souffrance est née beaucoup de bien
de vrais diamants sont sortis ils font
quoi
j'ai rencontré beaucoup de gens qui sont
des amis pour la vie
je n'ai pas remettre en question qu'ils
sont pour moi qui je suis pour eux voilà
qui est plus grand que moi c'est plus
important que tout
[Musique]
durringer rome laisse band
cela a été un honneur et une bénédiction
de pouvoir vous représenter en tant
qu'avocate mais plus important encore
j'ai eu la chance de devenir votre ami
une famille et essaie de vous que j'ai
appris la vraie signification de la
grâce dans la douleur
[Musique]